hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand new apple m1 powered macbook air
and in this video we're not only going
to take a look at different benchmarks
we're going to test out thermals but
we're also going to do things that other
channels haven't covered we're going to
run some terminal commands to see the
cpu frequency and the temperature test
the external temperature we're going to
do some x86 apps and see how those run
using rosetta 2 and much more and now
let's go ahead and do our signature
quick unboxing now i have to say that we
kind of told you guys so vadim has been
making apple silicon videos ever since
wwdc and he found out so much great info
for us so if you guys have enjoyed those
videos over the past few months give
this video a like to show vadim your
support
let's open this thing up here so as i
set this up i want to let you guys know
that we're going to be comparing this
macbook air to the previous one in a
bunch of different tests including
battery life as we run different
benchmarks thermals speakers microphones
webcams all of that stuff so make sure
you guys are subscribed you guys have
those notifications enabled let's go
ahead and get started with geekbench
five as you guys see this is the base
model macbook air with eight gigs of ram
and go ahead and hit run and one thing i
want to comment on right away is that
this thing is really cool to the touch i
barely feel any warmth here and i was
just outside with cold hands with the
previous 2020 macbook air as soon as i
downloaded installed all the programs
like i just did the fan was actually
ramping up already and it was quite warm
and we have our score
and wow
my mind is blown vadim hyped it up but
he wasn't wrong our single core score
here destroys every apple computer and
even the brand new 5950x which has a
shocking single core score and as far as
multi-core score this 999 dollar macbook
air or 8.99 actually beats out the very
best 16-inch macbook pro with the 2.4
gigahertz i9 processor that's at least 2
700 you have to spend compared to 9.99
that is insane now before i see if we
can get a readout on the sensors and the
temperature and frequency let's go ahead
and switch over to the graphics as you
may know this base model has a 7 core
gpu not the 8 core which you can buy for
more money and that actually comes in on
the 13 inch macbook pro and the mac mini
so we'll see what we get alright and
once again
this is crazy because this is the lowest
slowest m1 chip and graphics that there
ever will be we got a score of 18
881 and to put that into perspective
intel's new xe graphics that we were
very impressed by that scores roughly 15
000 on the highest and chips they have
slower ones and then the 16-inch macbook
pro that scores about 24 000 or so so
this thing with a 7 core gpu is getting
close to that i am very impressed and i
can't wait to test out the higher end
models so this is interesting i'm trying
to install lightroom so we could test
out the x86 emulation for photo editing
and it's telling me to install rosetta
so it looks like it's not natively
installed it's there it's actually
downloading it which is interesting that
was quick we're installed
bam your regular intel base apps are
working here's lightroom classic let's
hit install and we get a pop-up saying
it's the intel version that is fine they
do have a beta of photoshop for apple
silicon and we'll test out the beta
compared to the regular one in our next
comparison and now let's get into
thermals i want to see if i can get some
of these sensors reading out to us and
nothing so and now for icesat menu i'm
seeing my cpu usage let's go and open it
up seeing graphics usage no memory yet
but processor is working let's go and
open up terminal and try that out so it
looks like we have some info here we can
get gpu cpu usage some frequency but
unfortunately the command for the cpu
temperature is not working that's okay
we have some other methods so let's go
ahead and run our cinebench r23
and we'll see what kind of throttling we
get here now i'm gonna do this test a
little different compared to some other
people i'm not going to do the 10 minute
test just yet we're going to start off
just with a single test and we're going
to loop it multiple times manually that
way we can actually get to see the first
score the second score the third score
and see how much of a percentage of
performance we lose as time goes on
we're about two thirds done with the
first test and we're still at roughly
about 28 degrees celsius at the hottest
part right above the f3 key now as far
as frequency it looks like it's changing
a little bit now
we're down to 2 800.
it started off at about 3 000. so we're
looking at 27.67
of course the system is completely
silent there's no fans whatsoever now
it's looking like we're at 26.50
megahertz or 2.65 gigahertz and the
wattage is at basically 10 watts so it's
limited right there our first test is
almost done we're going to see the score
and restart
7401 is our first result and we did see
that it actually was throttling a little
bit close to the end of the first test
we're almost done with the second run
here and it looks like we're at 2.46
gigahertz now and the wattage is at 8.3
watts instead of 10 so obviously we see
that the frequency is dropping down
basically 2.45 gigahertz after the
second round so
67.35 and after the second run it looks
like we are at about 34 degrees celsius
so we are getting some more heat now
still definitely not bad but the people
that said that this thing doesn't
throttle for a long time well if we take
a look at the numbers we could see that
it does throttle now another thing i
have to mention is that the old macbook
air which we'll be comparing in
tomorrow's video
that one would hit 100 degrees almost
instantly like 10 seconds after you run
it you're already at 100 degrees the fan
starts ramping up which there was a fan
in there and then it just gets loud and
stays really loud and very hot six runs
almost done it's interesting that the
wattage actually went up to 7.4 now so
it looks like it's cooling itself down
with the lower wattage
and as far as frequency we're looking at
2.38
so it's staying right around there and
our score is 63.84
so it stayed actually got a little bit
higher than the fifth run so this is the
end of our cpu thermal limitations here
and it looks like we're now at 35
degrees so before we look at gaming
let's look at our final thermal
throttling and overclocking results we
started out with 7401
and 2.65 gigahertz so it did drop from
three gigahertz and the next run was
67.35 then 66.53
65.99 63 13 and then back up to 63.84
so realistically from the best
performance you can expect all the way
down to the worst the difference there
is roughly 15
not as big of a difference as we
expected when we found out this machine
was fanless and then it goes from 10
watts at full performance down to about
7.2
at the minimum now i also want to
comment on heat i just picked up this
laptop and it is warm on the bottom but
it is nowhere near as hot as the
previous macbook air with an intel cpu
was that thing was burning at the bottom
and then as far as the top temperature
here let's test this one more time
we're looking at 33.3 right now and the
highest i saw it hit was about 35 so
barely any change on the top that is
awesome i went ahead and averaged all of
those runs and i got 66 80 average with
throttling accounted for so that is very
impressive and just to put into
perspective for you guys the base
16-inch macbook pro scored 7043
in i think probably was three or four
different runs just the auto 10 minute
run and this thing has a six core
processor it's running at 45 50 watts it
has dual fans and it scores roughly five
percent higher than this macbook air
with thermal throttling that is crazy
now let's get into gaming we're gonna
start with heaven here as you guys can
see it is bouncing here wait was that it
so that was rosetta translating the app
i thought it was gonna take about 20
seconds or so but that was just a few
seconds i'm gonna go ahead and open up
the extreme preset so this is
interesting the benchmark is running
we're getting our fps counter here um
the results are impressive but we're not
seeing anything on the screen that could
be because opengl isn't working anymore
so we'll see what the results show but i
don't think we'll be able to go off of
this test so we do have our score but
first i want to point out that our gpu
was completely maxed out you see it's
still running in the background like
heaven does 99 usage and as far as
wattage here we're seeing right around 7
watts and the most i saw was 7.9 watts
which seems to be the maximum for this
gpu now that is crazy because a lot of
the other dedicated graphics
chips inside the 16 inchers those run at
50 watts
and just the performance per wattage is
absolutely insane now the score that we
got was 94.9
i can't go off of this score that seems
way too high we're seeing that we are
running virtual apple which means that
it is being emulated it's not a native
uh native application so that's very
interesting let's go ahead and move on
let's take this to another level we just
downloaded league of legends keep in
mind this is another x86 app this is not
one that's optimized for apple silicon i
got worried there for a second it took
about 15 seconds or so until it turned
on and that must have been rosetta 2. so
we're in the game here and it looks like
we're above 100 fps went all the way up
to 126 122
definitely really good frame rate let's
go ahead and go into the settings and
see what we're defaulted to so it looks
like 1440 by 900
let's go ahead and select the native
resolution which is 2560 by 1600 it's
pretty high there and now we're at 78
frames per second 77 76
still pretty good above 60 fps of course
it's silent because we're fanless here
let's go back in the settings we're
already at the increased quality
settings the slider is all the way over
let me go ahead and max out the
environment quality
the shadow quality effects quality
everything is maxed out and we're
playing a higher than 1440p and now i'm
moving around here we're seeing 67 fps
68 67
pretty consistent 64. 63.
ah let me get out of the way no
trying to look at frame rates so right
there 51 is the lowest i saw now we're
still rendering the scene 59 57 62
that's with everything maxed out and
we're playing at higher than 1440p
definitely better than i expected that
is seriously impressive and keep in mind
this is not an apple silicon optimized
app this is being emulated under rosetta
and is playing back maxed out settings
nice and smooth i'm not getting any lag
or anything like that like it is a
native app so it's been over five
minutes the mac is at 32 degrees in the
hottest point so pushing the graphics
card to the limit we're not seeing any
graphics throttling and the system is
very cool and of course it's silent
instead of being loud with the old
macbook air so it looks like as far as
graphics we're not getting any
throttling if you want to see how the
previous macbook air performs running
this x86 app on an intel x86 processor
that will be coming up tomorrow in our
comparison to the previous macbook air
so make sure you are subscribed with
those notifications enabled now vadim
really wants to jump in uh in front of
the camera and give his opinion all
right so i have a 2018
base 15-inch macbook pro i tried playing
league of legends it's not smooth it's
glitchy you get dropped frames i had to
resort to playing tft and not actually
league of legends and i'm just blown
away that we're getting native
resolution everything maxed out getting
around 60 fps
and you have a dedicated graphics card
in that yes it has a dedicated chip and
this is under rosetta
not even optimized it's not even
optimized for apple silicon all right
now let's go ahead and open up lightroom
and we're going to take a look at photo
editing also emulated under rosetta as
you guys see it's bouncing down there
that was 10 seconds right there to do
that initial translation and after that
it's not gonna happen it's just gonna
open up automatically so here we go
these are 42 megapixel raw images from
the a7 r3
so these are massive files okay look at
that responsiveness right there under
rosetta
oh my goodness look at that
that is perfectly smooth i'm not getting
any latency at all
contrast
that's as good as a high-end imac
look at that
no difference let's go texture
literally that is instant no delay okay
so i have to do the brush test this is
where sometimes we'll start having
issues let's go exposure let's bring it
down
all right
tiny bit of lag there
okay now it's better dude this is
rosetta let me uh let me okay right at
the start a little bit of lag
and this is a pretty big change to the
raw file
and then it smooths out that is very
impressive um let's go ahead and
oh my goodness okay
let's go back
let's go fit whoops i want to get rid of
that brush there
okay look at this guy
okay angelica when you're editing this
show the footage from the surface pro x
um
how that was the windows version of this
there was extreme lag
moving and doing anything and here it is
extremely smooth and this is the base
model macbook air without a fan okay so
now it's going to be the real test we're
going to select all of these images and
we are going to export this and we're
going to take a look not only at the
time but also the ram because this only
has 8 gigs of ram i have my stop watch
ready let's go and hit export our cpu is
maxed out looks like the graphics they
were just at 50 now they're at 20 and i
do want to let you know all 50 of these
42 megapixel raw images do have a bunch
of changes on there so there's a lot of
stuff that needs to be processed we're
getting close to halfway done and it's
only been a minute and 29 seconds and it
looks like the cpu is maxed out pretty
much the whole time the graphics is
about 20
so if you are considering spending the
extra money to upgrade the cpu to get
the full 8 core gpu it's not worth it if
you're doing photo editing and tasks
like these because even here it's not
close to being maxed out we're almost
done here i wanted to check on ram and
it looks like we're using 6.6 gigs out
of 8 so it's actually not maxed out the
export is almost done
this is crazy it looks like okay there
you go 313 we got 4 minutes and 43
seconds for the base macbook pro so this
is a lot faster and then the high-end
1800 one which apple is still selling
that got three minutes and 28 seconds so
still slower and keep in mind that has
16 gigs of ram in lightroom does need
ram and on top of that
uh lightroom classic is optimized for
those intel processors this is running
under rosetta before it gets optimized
so it looks like
if you're somebody that's wanting to buy
a mac like this you want to wait for
your apps to be optimized realistically
you don't need to wait this is the
fanless version and it's running faster
than the macbook pros that have fans and
are optimized for lightroom wow i really
was not expecting that i was expecting
to get lag especially with the brushes i
was about expecting to be slower but it
isn't and for those of you guys
wondering about ram and if 16 gigs is
enough with the high-end option
man it looks like apple's unified memory
is running much more efficiently and you
don't need as much
because the difference between those two
high end and bass it wasn't a cpu
difference it was a ram difference in
this case we have eight gigs of ram and
it's faster than both so my next
question is how much faster is the
macbook pro to this system so we're
going to be testing out a bunch of
different things we actually have two
macro pros coming one with eight gigs of
ram one with 16. so if you guys want to
see our upcoming apple silicon videos on
these laptops in the mac mini click that
circle above to subscribe enables
notifications and if you want to see
another great video we have it right
over there thank you guys for watching
this has been max and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]